indicting thing do you think any of
that's going to be taking place you
think there's i don't know you like any
of that okay got it but i mean they've
been being indicted yeah i mean for
years they've been saying he's been
doing this and that and nothing ever
came of it and now they're raiding this
house i still don't believe until i see
it yeah what do you think
keith where are you at with that could
it happen
could it get that ugly where they may do
that to him to just eliminate the
competitor they impeached him twice for
this breathing so i wouldn't i wouldn't
put it past i mean what are they gonna
indict him for being orange
i mean he is guilty of that bro
i mean i mean you might not like you
know what i had to get over when i was
when i when i made that switch over to
conservatives
i always voted for people who i liked
and uh and that it brought that to my
head when you said that you don't vote
for people who you like you vote for
people who's gonna make you know that's
gonna make this a better place to live
you vote for that policies has nothing
to do if he's handsome
if you like him if he's charismatic he
has nothing to do with it i want an
[ __ ] in office if he's going to take
care of my family my rights and protect
our country you don't care if he's an
[ __ ] if he takes i don't care if he's
an [ __ ] yeah but see your objective
most people ain't objecting yeah
you know yeah well i'll tell you what uh
bill you guys uh watch bill maher ever
yeah yeah yeah okay he's getting more
and more leaning more well he's just the
typical democrat he's not far left he's
just that's what he was democrat
traditional liberal yeah but you talked
about being an [ __ ] right and i think
that's part of the reason that biden you
know is the president now because people
were sick of the [ __ ] tendencies but
i'm going to read you what bill maher
had to say he was basically
saying that there's the rise of the meh
voter the meh like ah
just i just don't ah trump
yeah you know this whole concept and he
said one of the reasons obviously you
know you as you know kind of comedian
type guys you'll appreciate this he said
they're basically saying there are so
many good reasons that for to give
democrats your vote again this is on
bill maher and he basically says
well things could be worse inflation
right the economy right there's no other
option because the other guy's a [ __ ]
dick
that's what he says on this and that's
how people basically process trump is i
totally understand that if maybe if
it'll benefit the country this is a good
question
if it benefits the country would you
rather have an [ __ ] in office or a
nice guy and the country kind of goes
down the hill
you know that's the kind of the the what
the country essentially grappling with
right now you're saying you'd rather
have the [ __ ] yeah i think for the
most part of trump in office i'm just
speculating i think if he's in office i
don't think putin invades ukraine
i think it's a huge possibility
you know yeah that's what's leading to a
majority of the inflation we do hear
that argument they they address this i
do hear that argument all the time and
you very well might be accurate the
other side the flip side people are
saying all right cool all right i don't
think trump if he was in office they
would invaded ukraine the other side is
basically saying cool maybe you're right
but now that the war is being fought
whose side would trump be on would he be
pandering to putin at this point would
he be basically sending a lot of money
ukraine these are the questions that the
left is basically responding with right
i'm not saying that's right or wrong
this is saying
if he was in office he would probably be
siding with putin i think i don't think
he'd be siding with anybody i think more
than anything he would be trying to side
with ukraine because he wanted his son
and a bod and son to be investigated i
think it would be more on ukraine side
the thing that what would have prevented
that whole war in ukraine is diplomacy
yeah putin's been saying it for years
decades
um ukraine is not to join um
nato yeah that's all they wanted they
got two putin's yeah they're in bed with
ukraine too much united states
ukrainians are like russian blood you
know that's what happened in ukraine is
like california breaking away from the
united states
and becoming
wants to join let's say uh china
china or russia
that's that's equivalent what ukraine is
trying to do the united states would
invade california
you might be in that best interest if
california wants to be a part of russia
what is the usa going to do
they're going to they're going to invade
california because they don't want
russia sitting right there with all
their arsenal they don't want communism
on that doorstep like that no
on their doctors i don't i don't i don't
think what's going on in ukraine is good
by any stretch what do you mean by that
who doesn't want who who doesn't want
communism on their doorstep the united
states
got it i see what you're saying what i'm
saying california turns to a communist
country they go with uh soviet union usa
is going to invade california
that's why i'm not siding with any side
by the way but i'm just giving you the
reasons why russia did what they did
yeah that's why they did if diplomacy
would've came in yeah a leader if
somebody leader yeah like maybe trump
maybe i don't know maybe i'm just wrong
but somebody's sitting down talking to
both sides they don't like this we can't
do this but we can do this
if we just if they just had three men i
mean it shouldn't even come to the uh
there's people dying in ukraine right
yeah it shouldn't even come to war
anymore because nowadays these wars
nobody wins none of these wars yeah i
mean like when you go to war nowadays
like it's not like back world war two or
one people actually won those wars these
wars that we have not nobody wins nobody
wins so when russia invaded ukraine it
could have been so many things done to
prevent from this ever happening so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]